haha the Joe Rogan experience I've only
had bear once and I did like it what I
had it was a grizzly but I've had a lot
of black bears I have no idea what kind
of bear this was I'm not too hip to the
bear population or bear bear genie a
genus of Far East Russia I was in a
banya which is a very communal thing in
Russia
mm-hm and so I'm in Khabarovsk
up in the far eastern north where it's
negative 30 degrees below at night and
I'm up there we're in this Banja and
having to bond you a banya is a is
basically just like a big sauna and so
butter there's it's a traditional setup
where they have a an oven with rocks and
stone and it's a they will put throw
water over the stones and things like
that it's not it's not exactly it's not
a dry one like a finish but it's it's a
similar to any other sort of sauna
setups as you can come across but it's
not a steam room and it's also famous
for they have a process where they take
these bundles of tree branches with
leaves and everything on them and
they'll use white oak eucalyptus other
and put blends together and what they'll
do is they'll take these two bundles
they'll whip the air around you as
you're sitting there they whack your
body with it and the these leaves these
bundles are made of mostly fresh so
there's still oil as they're still you
know live or there's still elements
within it's not fully dried out or
anything like that so this thing is all
being hit upon you and they'll hit your
feet and they'll do all this kind of
stuff to be honest so the first time
ever went through this this guy is like
beating my ass with these things and I'm
like okay I can get through this I'm
good I know there's gotta be healthy you
know I've read the Wikipedia it sounds
all great and I'm sitting there and and
you go through sessions like
three-minute sessions or whatever and
I'm on the third one which is like
towards the end and he's he's whacking
away and he's whipping these things
around me and circulating all this super
hot air
and I swear to God my pale ass sensitive
white boy skin was just felt like it was
on [ __ ] fire and to the point that I
started I'm like I got I gotta do the
name and so I get up and I'm yelling in
Japanese in Russia and jumping into a
cold pool because I I'm so [ __ ] up
from getting my ass beat by this little
Russian guy with a pile of sticks why
Japanese you don't [ __ ] know Japan do
you not know any Russian no my brain was
in a different place dude and yeah as
you can relate when when you're sitting
in those things and it's pretty [ __ ]
hot and you're trying to get through it
like sometimes you're just you're trying
to guess in the beating from the sticks
is like the next level right because
it's frustrating enough just dealing
with the heat well think about right so
you're sitting still and you're having
maybe you're having a tough sauna
session you're like okay if I don't move
enough I'll get through this all right
now this [ __ ] is is pretending
to be a [ __ ] helicopter spinning
around the room he's like a Beyonce
[ __ ] dance number getting all this
hot air blown all over you like flying
like yeah caressing it up your taint all
this [ __ ] like dude there's no way of
stopping this naked and having he's
hitting your taint with this blistering
he's hitting your whole body very rare
that a man hits your taint with sticks
very rare I can say that it does have
it's a it's got its destroy taint
really neglected part of the human body
I'm going to starch the whole the whole
taint specific movement around how you
need to massage and stretch the taint
and you have to you know I bet your
taint is all locked up a bit the fashion
dictate this just is keeping you from
able to kick properly
[Applause]